[Music]
the winner of Survivor Congrats are in
order for Bend rebug in the 34 year-old
former Marine was crowned the champion
on Survivor heroes versus healers versus
hustlers
[Applause]
little information on there
a short chapter Realty
et's Bryce sander was backstage at the
finale event he spoke with Ben right
after his big winning moment the man of
the hour is here congratulations Ben
Thank You Bryce thank you very much has
it hit you yet ah no no it's pretty
surreal standing here holding the
microphone
I can't imagine I'm so happy and this is
awesome all those weeks of waiting to
find out whose names are gonna get
pulled out in what order yeah
to see your name with the most votes
tonight what does that mean
you know I never got comfortable some
nights I'd tell my wife like I think I'm
item one and then the other day said
like no you know I get in so when it
went one one one across the board and
then Chris he pulled her second vote I
was I was pretty sure I lost you know
and so the next one was Ben and I was
like well the next one's gonna go
Chrissy and then it went bad again and
and yeah it was amazing
Bess it was awesome it was an awesome
finale to watch have you thought about
that that big check you're getting that
money's gonna go we're gonna figure out
how to save it instead of spend it first
and we want the money to work for us
what did it mean to have your kids watch
your whole journey especially with PTSD
to the forefront you know my kids
they're six and three they like to
challenge apart you know and if a
commercial come on maybe they're dead
but I don't think they fully grasped it
yet
you know it's just it would double year
down the road they'll appreciate we
watch yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah would
you come back and play again 100% my
wife Kelly said I she let me come back
and so that's all I made it I just
waiting on a call now
[Music]
you